all right everyone and hello and welcome
to Android design in action the first
episode of the year 2013 my name is
Roman Nurik hey guys happy new Adam
cleshea and hi I'm James California
rather than London as it may say but oh
yeah it says London we don't have trying
to time to change the the name card
below Nick it does say London but he is
actually recording or broadcasting from
Mountain View California
so today our episode is going to be a
little a little bit of both design and
development
not too much development you won't see
any code you'll see maybe like a few
little pointers to things in there but
but it'll be mostly you know kind of for
designers but developers should effing
pay attention so today's episode is
titled iterative improvements and what
that means is we're gonna take a look at
a very bare-bones starting point app and
this is not a real app it's just a
hypothetical app and we'll see how over
the course of a few kind of key steps we
can get it from a point of which it's
kind of you know nothing to be talked
about kind of a really ugly ish app
doesn't really you know create a great
reading experience to something that's
that's a little better than that before
we get started you guys have any any
comments on on I guess actually before
that the type of app we're going to talk
about is is a basic like article reader
not really an RSS reader like google
reader but basically something that has
a list of articles and the article
details should we just get started you
has any comments you wanna share before
you jump in yeah it's good all right
let's do it since we have tons of slides
so let's look at the bare bones app so
this is the starting point I'm sure many
of you have seen apps kind of like this
in the Play Store you know there there
are lots of issues at play here you know
a few first you know it's it's kind of
hard to tell the different articles and
on the left apart there's no action bar
this is using the the pre Android 4.0
Android 3.0 title bar that's got the
legacy menu button here all sorts of
things wrong
this and obviously you know there's lots
of you know wrong spacing metrics we'll
talk about all the details in a bit but
this is kind of our starting point so
like I said we're gonna jump through a
couple of different steps and along the
way we'll talk about what what is
involved in each step and how to
actually do it so the first step is to
change to the holo theme and add an
action bar to your app so you could see
here that you know the the holo theme
actually the holo theme automatically
gives you an action bar by default but
you have the action bar at the top and
what that gives you is that gives you a
sense of place and to where you are in
the app and which app you're in so you
see the little icon here as well as some
some basic actions that are immediately
available on the screen so things like
refresh if you want to be able to
refresh the list of articles as well as
an overflow giving you access to things
that usually you'd see and there's a
legacy menu button awesome yeah and just
from a developer standpoint you know
it's really a matter of enabling a
target SDK version for your application
in your manifest I think 11 or above
that obviously we recommend targeting
the latest platform version where you
where you can so in this case we just
put down here a little note that says
target SDK version of 17 and in addition
you know that there's a theme that you
can set for for holo so in this case
it's themed at holo light dark action
bar so that's the light theme down
bottom with a dark action bar at the top
and once one reasonable thing to pick
out here is if you take a look at the
background color in here you see it's
change from pretty much pure white to a
slightly off-white which is part of the
holo palette really and there's really
good reasons that we've selected these
kind of base colors for the for the base
things which you inherit from because
like whites on mobile can be like a
searingly bright color which you want to
use sparingly and it's not very great
for kind of a background color so and
you know it's a subtle change but it
instantly makes the app easier to read
it for sure and we've kept that
throughout so you'll see you know kind
of the evolution of this design with
with more branding elements and things
of that and we've kept that default
color
so let's move on what's the next step we
have an action bar we have you know the
holo theme that gives you a little bit
you know that improves the the visual
design a little bit but you know what's
the next step so the next step is to
customize the action bar and give your
app a little you know kind of touch of
branding so you'll see here that we've
chosen a an orange color palette and you
know again this is really up to you if
you have an existing service and
existing you know color scheme for your
brand you know introduce it this is the
best place I'd say in your app to
introduce branding is the action bar
since its kind of you know a key
structural element you know at the same
time it's a key kind of area to
differentiate and then the little icon
we chose here this is actually not a
standard launcher icon this is a custom
icon for the action bar and so remember
that you don't necessarily have to have
your exact pixel for pixel launcher icon
in the action bar you can customize it
so that it looks good in the in the kind
of context of the action bar and so the
launcher icon for this app would
probably be you know like an orange
circle with a white Y but we decided
that this kind of inverted color scheme
would look good here and you'll also
notice that we've introduced some of
those same branding elements well I
guess some of the same color scheme
elements throughout the content so for
example the by the way I should I should
preface that all the content here is is
meet specific it's a bunch of bacon and
chicken and steaks this is just kind of
example content so it's pretty Seiken
friendly color scheme actually you have
very very bacon oriented reading
experiences so what is it 7:30 a.m. over
there Nick yeah so you know links and
and other things throughout are accented
with this orange so that's that's the
next step and then yeah and then I guess
from a developer standpoint I think
actually Nick you had some blog posts up
on the developer vlog that outlined some
ways to theme the action bar but there's
also a great tool called the action bar
style generator if you're just Google
for it you'll find that which sort of
generates all those things for you so
you have to worry about all the all the
different types of elements and
attributes that you need to style
thanks very much yes all right moving on
so the next step and this is one of the
key most important steps this is I think
one of the key ways in which you know
polished apps and apps was really good
fit and finish differentiate from the
less polished apps is the margins and
the spacing the way they treat white
space and this is kind of one of a UI
designers best tools in creating
contrast and readability readability is
the concept of not necessarily
legibility of of you know paragraphs and
words but readability is a sense of like
you know given a block of text how easy
is it for the eye to consume that
information and adding margins and
spaces is one of the key ways to do that
so you'll notice that you know from that
previous screen we've we've tweaked the
spacing so that you can better separate
the the list of Arctic or the each
article in the list on the left from its
background and from the other articles
as well as we've added some standard 16
dip margins throughout the content on
the detail screen here and you'll
probably hear us often mentioned the
48dp rhythm from the design site so
that's really what all of this is based
off yeah and we'll show some red lines
at the end that show some of the
spacings that we use on tablets as well
and this is again one of the key ways in
which you differentiate phone or handset
from tablet to make sure that that again
that readability that that comfort and
reading is still there so let's move on
unless Nick yet Ania no greeting room I
think it's so much easier to stand now
yeah so the next step the next step is
another important way in which you can
introduce consistency and a strong
rhythm in your app is the way you treat
photo thumbnails so you'll notice that
in the previous version these photos
were kind of you know all jaggedy or
lopsided they didn't have a strong
rhythm because they had different aspect
ratios so one of the ways in which you
can you know I guess alleviate this is
to introduce a different type of scaling
and Adam could talk about that but
basically you'll notice here that all
the photos line up their full bleed edge
to
and they introduced kind of a strong
single line single line in your design
so it's very easy for the eye to
separate the text from the image and
from four to separate the images from
each other since there's kind of that
light separator there yeah and then from
the developer side there's an attribute
scale type which you can set to sent a
crop where the framework will actually
do this for you of course you know if
you're if you if you're pulling that
image from from a server side or
something like that you could have the
images come down at the right size
already but in many cases that's not
possible so this is actually a really
good way to make sure that they're all
lined up and of the same size I really
like this it just it really brings the
images out a little bit more and as you
say the lines really make a huge
difference there on the left before
version where you have been kind of
uneven readiness I suppose like a jagged
tooth pattern it looks like you kind of
have these goofy teeth it just isn't
right gonna scan yeah what you want to
avoid is you know if you look at your
design or your UI from you know like a
few feet away you don't want to see like
a New York City skyline right you want
to see consistent grids you want to see
rectangular grids and in some cases you
know for really complex interesting you
eyes you you probably want to you know
go just a little deeper than that you
want to do some more interesting things
but at the very most basic level if
you're simply presenting you know
collection of information you want to
you know make make sure that you're
establishing a grid now and establishing
you know single line so that it's very
easy for the eye to kind of follow the
flow of information okay moving on I
think the next step is one of the
biggest and this is something that we
haven't we've touched on I guess a
million times in the show but typography
I think you know what you'll see is the
difference that just a few attributes
can make in the in the I guess the
overall just visual aesthetic but also
just the ease and consuming information
so let's go to the next section on
typography so you'll notice that here
and this is this is more like micro
typography where we've looked at the
treatment of text at the individual
character level I guess it's a
combination of macro and micro macro
being
you know the typography that's that's
kind of creating the the general figures
of text the general blocks of text in
this case we've looked at the micro
aspect of that so if we look in here to
the detail or to the list screen you'll
notice that each of the articles the in
each of the articles the title stands
out a little more
it's a Roboto bold condensed and the
subtitle the 18 minutes ago by the
author that was kind of made more muted
since that's kind of less important
information once your eye settles on a
title that you want to read about maybe
at that point you then want to read
about the subtitle or you want to find
that who wrote that and so once your eye
settles on the title then you can kind
of make the small visual step to look at
who wrote it and when it was published
but this kind of really cleanly
separates each individual title from the
subtitle as well and then on on the
detail screen here we've done we've used
a similar treatment for the title here
we've again used Roboto bold condensed
condensed bold but then for the text
itself we've actually used a custom font
it's called rosario but this is is
generally you know not necessary to use
a custom font you can use one of the
Roboto variants for body text but we
found that in this case it may be
possible to kind of introduce this this
custom font in in a light way not using
it overly throughout the UI not making
every single UI element this custom font
but in this case it may improve
legibility so any any thoughts on
typography guys spacing as well oh oh
sure so another important aspect that
you should look at when when changing
fonts especially is the line spacing
this is kind of in typography terms it's
the letting is basically the space
between each line and this effects again
that readability aspect how easy is it
for the eye to move from one line to the
next as you get to the end of one line
jumping over to the next one and
starting that so all these things the
the spacing around the text the line
spacing between each line that's all
very important too
the readability and so here we've used I
think a multiplier of 1.2 but generally
if you feel that your text is a little
too cramped
don't don't underestimate the power of
introducing like a 1.1 or 1.2 line
spacing yeah and and from the
development side there's two attributes
generally you want to look at here it's
Android font family and Android line
spacing multiplier so those sort of
together allow you to achieve an effect
like this and I should mention that for
the four custom fonts and again use them
very sparingly in in key areas where it
may improve the experience for for
reading large blocks of text in in for
custom typefaces you may want to look at
Google web fonts Rosario for example is
oil is available from Google web fonts
and it hints really really well on
mobile so that's another key important
thing is you make sure to not just pick
a font based on what it looks like on
the web you would actually try it out on
a few devices and make sure that it
looks really crisp because some fonts
some TTF files don't actually have
really good hinting instructions and so
when they're taken down to smaller sizes
they're not going to look very good
they're just going to have be off and
not very well aligned so that's
something that it's definitely important
to try and not just on on the web but on
mobile as well shall we move on let's
just want to say I think the use of
different font weights is very good way
for giving structure to your content
like I think exactly what Roman was
saying about how you want to make this
kind of strap and then 18 minutes ago
kind of received visually but we like
you know edge books you need it just
favor
glancing at this you know this screen
should I be look away and look back you
just stands out the structure of the
content and what you want to read first
and it's so much easier to scan the page
now yeah this console the visual
hierarchy is very important you want to
make sure to highlight to establish a
visual hierarchy in terms of what is the
top level item and then what are its sub
items in this case you know the top
level item is the title right the title
of the article is basically you know the
the name that you would put in the tree
for the article
that would be its title so the subtitle
as well as as but as its body content is
kind of a child of that so that should
kind of be lower individual hierarchy so
it should stand that a little less again
once your eye hits the title then it
could move on to to the sub items in
that tree you know go ahead and read
details about that alright moving on so
alternatively we actually created an
alternative presentation this is
something that that doesn't work in
every case and I think in this case
actually doesn't work super well but
alternatively you could combine photos
and in text and this is something that a
couple of popular apps do now but what
you could do is combine photos and text
just make sure that again your your text
lines up so here you'll notice that the
text still lines up with where the title
still lines up with the subtitle and it
lines up with the body as well so that's
that's again very important to establish
those clear lines for alignment so if
you use a visual treatment behind a text
to give it some contrast because you
kind of right yeah so there's um there's
a little bit here in the sense of like
we use a gradient and we've shown this
in the past with I think it was Trip
Advisor's redesigned make you you use
that effect but we we use a gradient a
light dark or a light black gradient so
it fades from like about like a thirty
forty percent opaque black to zero
percent of pic blank so that content
along the bottom has stronger background
protection so if the image itself let's
say you know this image of the steak if
the whole image is actually white then
you'll still be able to read the text
because of that background protection
okay so since we're running low on well
I guess sort of low on time let's kind
of start flying through some of these so
we also added a viewpager to make sure
that you can swipe between the detail
screens this is fairly straightforward
using the view pager from the support
library it's white keys well documented
on the design side mm-hmm
and you should where possible introduce
this into your detailed view so you can
very quickly sweat between items so
let's jump into tablet this is let's
let's look at like a flashback to our
step 0 if we were to run that step 0
like starting point on a tablet this is
what it would look like so you'd have
two separate screens that that just
makes horrible use of space you have all
these large regions of white space here
at the bottom you also have very large
line lengths we'll talk about that which
makes reading really a pain so as you're
reading like the first line here here
here here here then it's time to go on
to the next line your eyes trying to
move to the next line but it's very hard
for it to find the next line because
it's just not like this this text that's
too long of a measure so we'll we'll
talk about that how to improve them and
of course the image is a tiny right in
this particular view so you know in a
tablet that's not making very good use
of the space
yeah pretty terrible overall if this is
your tablet experience this is pretty
bad if you fix it so let's say we were
to you know fast forward and just use
you know use all those tricks of spacing
and everything and see what that would
look like in the tablet you know it's
much better it's still not great right
because you still have those long lines
you still have that image that we're now
the aspect ratio is completely different
from the source material so you only see
the very middle strip of the image which
is fine it doesn't look too bad in this
case yeah that's still a strictly bacon
you can't go wrong with that we could do
better than this right so the next step
is to create a two-pane UI so in this
case what we've done here is we've
simply combined the master and detail
into a single two-pane UI and this is
you know fairly straightforward we have
a you can actually do file new in
eclipse you can do file new master
detail flow to get you the basics for
this but there's also some articles you
could read yeah developer.android.com
slash training has a two really good
training class little bit yeah so it's
fairly straightforward to do it these
days there's a lot of pre-written code
for you it's it is a fairly complex code
if you
the beginner but it's kind of like file
new and you're done and you can read
about the details you in this training
articles so moving on how would we then
improve this so what we can do is now
start tweaking the again the margins and
the spacing the different dimensions on
tablets so that you know when you when
you open up the same detail view on a
tablet you'll actually get you know
larger text for example you get more
spacing around the sides to again better
separate the figure from the ground
better separate the text from its
background you can bump up font sizes
you can bump bump up line spacing again
lots of things you can do here to make
it better and it's really easy from the
development side as well
yeah I mean hopefully when we're talking
about the phone side you extracted all
of the different dimensions padding
spacing into a separate XML file and
then you can choose sort of when you
want to bump those up again at which
which screen size will bump them up so
in this example then the bump here to
small Swit 600 DP and at 720p for seven
and 10-inch tablets respectively but of
course it's up to you when you want to
tweak those sizes this is just sort of
the standard what we would recommend
yeah but for looking at different sizes
and you can provide multiple switch
points right so you can have a different
metrics on a you know five inch 17 yeah
for sure and actually one one that we
don't often talk about is small devices
so devices that have really small
screens you may want to you know tweak
things even further there maybe even
start compressing information into like
separate navigable sections if your if
your user base is on small devices then
again that's something that you want to
do using something like SW 300 or 200 DP
or values - small for example all right
so let's let's actually look at some of
the metrics here take a quick sidebar so
you'll notice that and again this still
uses the 48dp rhythm in the sense that
you know things are generally multiples
of 48 or 16 and for smaller sizes we use
a 32 16 24
eight things like that powers of powers
of two and things divisible by four
roughly so here's your some of the quick
examples you know generous margins
around the content here I mean a TDP if
you're not using something as large as
like 80 or 64 DP for margins and a
tablet then you probably should be since
you know you really want a lot of space
so that you can really the I can
comfortably read the content and then
the font size here is fairly large 48
ESPYs okay let's also look at that same
alternative so again with the photo
behind the text it's even more evident
here that there's a background gradient
but again the key point here is that
you'll notice that the alignment is
still there the text still aligns so
that the eye can very quickly read we've
been talking a lot about reading if
you're interested in reading more about
this lookup macro typography as well as
readability there's a lot of great
articles out there on how to best kind
of create a very readable experience
let's keep flying through so some extra
credit things that we did
what could a notification be like let's
say you're your blog author or an author
and you're posting stuff to this bacon
site you know let's say that there's
some sort of background process that you
know says you know the photos uploading
the text is uploading what could a nice
notification be you could get a
notification with kind of a preview of
the photo that everything's been
uploaded and then when you swipe over
you'll notice or when you swipe down
you'll notice that the expanded version
actually has that photo lets you maybe
shared the article and this is all very
easy to do from a developer standpoint
yeah there's a class called notification
compat which i think we've mentioned
before that allows you to build these
rich notifications from your platform
versions but remain backward compatible
with older versions yeah definitely
definitely good to use yeah super super
trivial I'd say to use it's only like a
couple lines of code we're also working
on a template you can do file new
notification it will just build all this
code for you
so moving on another quick tidbit is if
you're if you're using a webview for
presenting content then you're
automatically going to get this but if
you're not if using a text view by
default your text will not be selectable
so if you long press on the body content
nothing will happen
so there's a really neat little trick
that you can do you can set a single
attribute on your text view and this is
more for developers of course that makes
that tech selectable and from there you
can obviously customize you can say you
know allow people to share this text or
copy it and so on I'm surprised
surprised that attribute is called text
is selectable is very simple all right
let's keep moving on okay so I think
this is the last step here this is what
it looks like so you guys remember from
the very beginning you know the very
very beginning starting point was yeah
it was just all over the place
didn't look good on a tablet the spacing
was awful it was hard to kind of pick
out the articles from each other the
photos weren't well lined the typography
was you know just very bare-bones and so
with just a few tweaks and I think that
actually all these screenshots are
screenshots they're not Photoshop
mock-ups I think overall it took us you
know a few hours to put this all
together you know each one of these
tweaks is very incremental it's it's
minor iteration right it's not like a
revolutionary design by any means so
with very little work I'd say you can
get to this point so you should
definitely eat to it alright with that
and unless you gives any final thoughts
no I think it's been really awesome to
kind of show you the processes and the
things that you think about and look at
in a redesign go ahead please yeah it
makes me want to eat some bacon ASAP
yeah we're past lunch but I think Nick
is is almost there so let's jump into
Android design news so we don't have too
much design news today Nick you want to
start with good there's blog post yeah
so you can fail in the guy's room
Apolo
did a really really good blog post
talking about me and the importance and
the opportunity of using widgets and you
with your application and I think they
really summed up the opportunity here
for me that you know this is a prime
piece of real estate on the user's
device where most of they use a journey
start from and you get to kind of show
you know another avenue through your
content and have a really quick and easy
way to put stuff on their home screen
that it's kind of a sharing one many
apps don't offers functionality so
really think about how widgets might
work with you with your app new content
absolutely next up we have from Taylor
we have the wireframe screen flow
template I'll briefly just mention that
you know it's very important to map out
the different interactions in your app
not just the visuals you know so like
when you touch this what happens when
you when you pinch here or a double
touch here or swipe here what happens
and so this is a great starter template
for basically giving you the the
different gestures that you'd want to do
as well as linking up different screens
using these little red arrows so if
you're if you're starting from scratch
you may want to just start from this
point if you're mapping out the
interactions within your app it kind of
helps you think about an navigation as
well so if you think you have like
multiple routes into your content to say
we've done a widget for the and the
bacon up we just been looking at you
know you might come into a detail screen
so it helps you to think about how the
parent like a hierarchy might work as
well absolutely
moving on we have okay so at this point
we should talk about the different
communities out there so there are two
communities and these are evidenced by
our two slides here there's the official
Android design community on Google+ if
you haven't joined it you know feel free
to join there there is an issue
currently with the community in the
sense that there's a lot of spam and
send a lot of kind of off-topic posts
we're currently exploring ways in which
we can make the community more valuable
provide more value for everyday
designers so definitely you know if you
have some questions or if you like you
know want to start a discussion thread
about a certain topic feel free to post
here with this
their rice also is like designed TP
request and so on right wasn't free yeah
if you have any questions about your
design if you want you know folks in the
general public to to provide comments in
your design feel free to post a few
screenshots I'd avoid posting links to
apps because that can be viewed as kind
of spammy but if you could put some
screenshots though you know folks
generally are good about providing
feedback
yeah the discussion seems to spooling
around like the specific question like
how do you feel about my spacing on X
kind of thing rather than what do you
think yeah alright and then there's also
the unofficial Android designers
community which I believe they have a an
approval process but it's like fairly
lightweight so and this is more for like
professional Android designers like if
you're doing design work for you know
for a company for a client or even for
your own company that you work for and
that's your kind of core job this may be
this is kind of like a more advanced
more kind of I'd say it may be like
higher level thinking community there's
there's lots of good content on here so
I advise joining both at this point okay
and I think lastly kahin oh I'm gonna
butcher name I'm sorry
Kohi Middleton has posted a PSD version
of all of the the icons in the action
bar icon pack available on developer to
answer that Comstock design /downloads
he's posted that in a PSD format so if
you don't use illustrator or if you
don't have illustrator and you just want
the shapes in PSD format then this may
be you know for you so yeah Oh actually
there's one more yes Michael
Laura McCallister has done a great job
in taking all of the slides from
episodes one through twelve of the show
basically everything we did in 2012 and
putting them into a single zip file so
if you've wanted that if you don't feel
like going through all the Google+ posts
and fetching all the screenshots and all
that it's available in a single zip file
available on its Dropbox if he decides
to take it off of his Dropbox then you
know
sorry but he's done he's done everybody
a favor in doing this so thank you you
go alright with that I think that's our
last slide with that any parting
thoughts one more piece of news actually
and I've got to add it into the into the
show but I just saw it and was the
screenshots from the communities if
you're in London there's an event going
on in the Google campus building on the
25th and 26th of January so next next
weekend's design and developers kind of
coming together and talking about
designing for Android so if you can make
it see London then check it out for more
information go to the London GDG the
Google developers group go to their
Google+ page you find all the details
cool okay
all right well thanks for joining us in
Android design in action as always I'm
Roman Nurik at a push in Nick butcher
see you guys later
see you bye peace out